[Music]
awesome well happy Thursday everybody
and welcome to the data science hangout
hope everyone's having a great week it
was so awesome to get to meet so many of
you at the posit conference in Chicago
and so happy to be back with everybody
this week hope you had a great time with
Robert last week thanks Robert for
covering for me I was out of the office
and got to go to France last
week but for anybody I haven't had the
chance to meet yet I'm Rachel Dempsey
and I'm the host of our data science
hangout here in lead customer marketing
at posit so this is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and really just
getting to hear what going on in the
world of data across all different
Industries and so we're here every
Thursday at the same time same place so
if you're watching this recording on
YouTube later you can also add it to
your calendar if you ever want to join
us live it will be in the details below
and James I think that's where you first
came across the Hangouts as you were
watching a lot of them on YouTube too
yeah I've become a bit of a an I've
become a bit obsessed with programming
YouTube so I I watch quite a lot of like
programming tutorials programming um
like conference talks online and uh yeah
play YouTube through the through the
television so awesome um it's quite a
quite a constant stream for me love it
well at the The Hangout we're all
dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everybody so we love
hearing from everyone no matter your
years of experience titles industry or
languages that you work in too and and
so it's totally okay for you to just
listen in maybe you're out for a walk or
on your lunch break or something but you
can also jump in uh and ask questions or
provide your own perspective on certain
topics so you can raise your hand here
on zoom and I'll keep an eye out you
could put questions in the zoom chat and
just put a little star next to it if
it's something that you want me to read
out loud otherwise I'll just call on you
to introduce yourself and add some
context and then lastly we also have a
slide link where you can ask questions
anonymously too and our uh team will
share that in the chat in just a second
here but with all that I am so excited
to be joined by my co-host today James
lar Smith data scientist at the bank of
England and James I love to kick things
off by having you introduce yourself and
share a little bit about your role a
little bit about the work you do and
also something you like to do outside of
work yeah sure thanks for having me it's
great to be on so yeah uh like you
introduced uh my name is James I am a
data scientist at the bank of England
where I kind of work on as like an
internal data consultant so as we'll get
on to like the the bank is quite big and
so I I partner the team of which I'm
part uh we partner with different
business areas in order to try and um
improve their data science workflows and
to to to bring kind of a best practice
to to the work that that they do I am
also sort of separately um uh I have the
a kind of a specific title of our
business owner which is uh something
which I'm not sure exists in many places
I hadn't heard about it before I joined
the bank but as part of that I am kind
of the uh the business's
representative uh of of the of the Tool
uh which means I I attend some meetings
where where some some things about R are
decided upon and uh various um there's
also a component of of testing and
people can can ask more more about that
if they like um but but yeah so I I I
play quite a key role in in the at very
least the r language but probably data
science more more broadly at the at the
bank of England uh I I should also maybe
say uh because this is a frequent source
of uh misunderstanding uh the bank of
England is uh the UK's Central B
so some people uh think it's a it's a
retail bank but it's not so for those
joining from the United States it's it's
much more akin to the the Federal
Reserve um people who who are from
elsewhere know it as the bank of
Australia or the bank of Japan or the
European Central Bank so we're not a
retail bank we we're the um the Central
Bank um for the for the United Kingdom
yeah thank you for that clarification
too and and I'll Echo what Lisa said in
the chat that it's awesome that you get
to represent our the whole organization
too and okay what about something you
like to do outside of work too ah yes I
forgot very good very good so um I think
uh there's uh I think for uh people what
people sometimes will notice is about my
accent uh which is not something I do
outside work the accent is the same at
work and outside work but um it's uh I I
happen to be a South African so I I only
came to the UK about uh just under six
years ago now um and so I have a perhaps
a slightly different perspective as as
somebody who who learned programming uh
o overseas in in Africa and um that
gives me a slightly different
perspective to to some people I think
that the thing that people most know me
forough I don't do it that much anymore
is I I used to be very involved in
competitive debating so at at high
school and and University for for a long
time I I did I Deb competitively um
debating is something which is mainly
based out of schools and universities
and so I don't I don't do it that much
anymore but um that's that's something I
dedicated quite a lot of free time to
not a lot of data science overlap with
um with uh with competitive debating but
if you ask me about it I'll I'll tell
you about what what what they have in
common it's like we're going to have to
learn a little bit about that we might
just have to start
there what are what are a few of the
things that they have in common or what
lessons have you learn from your
experience
debating the the answer is not not much
so like I said before it's a bit of a
stretch to say that there's um that
there's anything really that much in
common um if I if I out a stretch I
would I would say that uh even uh even
in um in both roles a lot of debating is
uh what we call impromptu so it's um uh
so we only get a short time to prepare
but that makes is quite good at like
brainstorming so sometimes when I when I
do some some modeling statistical
modeling uh some of the activity is to
uh to try and imagine what the forces
that are in play in your model are so
what's really happening uh in the real
world and debating has some of that so
when you when you scope out an argument
uh very often you have to kind of get
like hypo hypothetical Societies or
hypothetical people in your in your your
mind um to to try and um uh like
understand what's going on so at a
stretch I think that's probably the
similarity uh of course the the the the
skills on the skills level uh is very
useful to be able to speak in front of
people and to have practice speaking in
front of people um because that that has
uh obviously widespread use uh not just
in data science but but in lots of
professional
capacities thank you something I forgot
to say UPF front but I wanted to add
that in case anybody's joining for the
first time there's always like a party
happening in the chat as well and people
sharing links and resources with each
other so like perfectly okay and awesome
to do that too so I just like to remind
people of that so if you have resources
you want to share feel free to use the
chat there for that
too um but James when we were talking um
a few weeks ago now you had mentioned to
me that the bank has 4,000 employees and
I think like close to a thousand of them
use R and I was just curious to learn a
little bit more of that because that
just seems like a huge number of users
for the size of the orc too yeah so I
think the thing to understand is I
always think of the bank of England as
just a giant data Factory so like we
have a huge amount of data going in and
a Hu like a broad uh a broad set of data
going in um and of course we produce
outputs uh which which go to uh which
get published and come out in in various
other capacities um so the weird thing
is not so much that we have a thousand R
users the thing is we should have more
actually so it's just that data is just
so Central to basically every facet of
uh what it what the the bank does that
uh actually our a lot of our aim is to
try and get get more people into into R
and the data science languages um I have
some I have like a brief breakdown which
I kind of prepared for this which I
think is maybe instructive uh on on this
point so the bank is hugely varied in
the kind of things that it does so the
the one there's like one at least one
sort of uh division of the bank which is
a bit like an investment Bank like or a
hedge fund or a mutual fund um and their
thing is a bit like time series uh and
and the usual things you would think of
like quantitative um finance and stuff
like that but then there's another area
of the bank which is like uh an academic
Department who's P primarily involved in
publishing papers and research and uh
you know they they will they publish in
latch um and and use quarter and things
like that um there's also a huge amount
of the bank which is like just
operational so you know we we have
operational data for example we collect
data on like Bank notes right so you
know just the physical currency which
that's a that's an operational division
of the of the bank but also you know
collect data and and we we we use that
data to make decisions so my experience
is actually that um and there's also
areas of the bank which are just like
basically like a text data so you know
that's just uh you know not on toward
you know something you might see it like
Google or Facebook or something like
that um so all of those things just mean
that data is uh ever present in our
activities and our and the work that we
do so um a lot of our it's not like we
have too many we we have too few users
despite the fact that we have sort of uh
sort of a thousands or something like
that the other thing maybe to to know
for people who might be might not know
is we actually have good Telemetry on
this so we we sort of keep track of uh
the number of users of all our different
tools uh and so it's not just like we we
count downloads or something like that
we actually uh we we have fairly good um
uh fairly good knowledge of exactly who
uses what tools and and what they they
use them for so it's not an exact sign
so it's about it's about a thousand
users over the course of a year um have
have have used our or our
studio thank you for that context too I
see a few questions starting to jump in
here in the chat and Allan I see you had
asked a question a bit ago do you want
to jump in here first and sorry if my
internet just cut out for a second I
think uh is it okay does it sound okay
now yeah okay um but Alan I I'll start
reading it and if you want to jump in
after the question was you're the
business champ for R is there an IT side
owner as well and how do you work
together yes absolutely so so the idea
is that yeah we have a technology owner
um which is yeah much like it and we
have a business owner and yes we do
absolutely work together so the
technology owner unsurprisingly is is
often uh somebody from uh sort of the uh
CIS admin type of of role so so people
are responsible for uh you know
everybody's uh everybody's Tech
infrastructure um and the the the
business un sorry the business owner is
designed to be separate from that so
it's designed to be much it's much more
common that this person would be a data
scientist it's much more common that
this person you know would be working
dayto day um so it's it's uh it's a part
of my role but it's not my my entire
role and and um uh but yeah we we
absolutely work together and we the
technology owner and I sort of shoot
each other questions every day there are
areas of overlap but um but we kind of
need to do different things the other
thing which the the the business owner
also meant to be a kind of like Champion
so if there's something wrong with the
tool it's you know we we have some some
administrators because the the bank is
very big we have a team of
Administrators um it's my job to to
raise issues when they when they come
about to be a kind of sounding board for
um for the users in general so um well
at least that's how I interpret it um
that's um I I think the the common
practice so sometimes have to walk a bit
of a tight rope so um balancing
different different users interests
thank
you oh Alan we can hear you
now than Laura I see you had a question
um somewhat related as well do you want
to jump in here
uh yeah so um it's tagging on to that
and it's related to you know when
there's two owners of one thing
obviously there's never just like you
said there's a lot of overlap and it
sounds like you and your it owner have a
good partnership and you work really
well together um but have you had to
weigh the you know there's ownership and
then there's territorialism and in every
organization I've ever worked at there
are some people who have just moved into
the
territorialism niche and not you know
like oh that's an IT job not my job kind
of situation oh that's a data side
that's how do you besides it sounds like
you have a great relationship with your
it person I have an awesome relationship
with my it person but how do you balance
that and ensure that you're meeting
business needs while not
siloing yeah yeah so so great question
mercifully I have been been saved from
this particular quandry by the the same
way I think you have um a lot of our uh
if if there are tensions they tend to
come in
prioritizing so where I have to um uh uh
judge not like whether something is
important because oftentimes When
anybody comes to me with something it's
very important for them um so the the
the trade-offs that I have to make and
pay attention to or what the the
majority of users are likely to find
Troublesome and that's that's often a a
judgment call um uh and uh
thankfully have never needed to to
escalate that the bank is very collegial
in in that respect um but if so then
there is a kind of a chain of of of
command so there there is my my boss and
my boss's boss um who are the official
people in charge so we do have a we do
have a chain of command as it were um
where if a tough decision does need to
be made then um uh then there there is
somebody who who is uh who is in charge
of that uh on the on that same note uh
the the the metric that I kind of uh a
lot of it is individual the metric I try
and use to assess these things it's
important to be mindful of people who
don't complain so people who have like
tried to use a tool but have given up
because it's it's too difficult and I
have to always be aware that I don't
hear from those people because they've
given up and there's kind of a selection
bias there um which is you know you
don't hear from the people who've given
up um and so one of the things which uh
I'm I'm working on right now and we'll
continue to try and work on is is just
getting package installs correct so we
have a set of our own internal R
packages and um usually the process is
quite streamlined but of course if if
there is a problem then that's a very
big stumbling block especially for a new
user but can be for for an existing user
so things like that I I tend to
prioritize quite highly um and I I will
give I will sort upweight in terms of
their
importance um but yeah it's it's it's
it's it's not the easiest thing to do
and and requires judgment and
experience I see um Mike and Bill you
have two kind of similar questions
you're asking around um cross-government
agency groups Bill do you want to jump
in here do you want me to read it the
question was um as part of a government
agency is there a cross-governmental
Agency Group perhaps Loosely affiliated
with a focus on our or other languages
and perhaps emerging
Technologies uh we are trying so so
there there are definitely people who
use uh uh who use are across the the the
government sector we also have an
overlap of uh employees so some
employees like leave the government
sector or leave some part of the
government sector come to the bank and
vice versa and so uh we have pretty good
relationships there uh not quite to to
where it could be and there's there's
definitely more uh more sharing that
that that could be done like and that's
uh that that could also extend to to
data sharing um and there there are some
agreements for for data sharing that uh
that exist but yeah definitely
definitely room to to grow on that one
Mike did you have any follow-up question
you want to add there I know your
question was similar too well it was
more that within Pharma industry we're
engaging quite a lot in discussions with
the Regulatory Agencies you know FDA
being a good example to Define what they
want to see from us when we interact
with them um I've been talking to one or
two people from different parts of
Finance who've then said well it would
be fantastic if there was a similar
discussion between you know various
bodies and financial Regulators to say
you know are we giving you what you want
can we modernize this
you know and and have that kind of
two-way
discussion yes so there's there's a
couple Avenues on this and uh there
there are um many lines of communication
and a lot of them truthfully do not do
not cross my path um because like I said
like the the bank being quite broad um
there'll be different areas of uh for
example Insurance be different to to
banking the one thing we are trying to
do uh quite hard is is modernize our um
submissions so what happens uh it's
probably similar in Pharma you you will
know but for in the financial services
and and finances industry in general is
a lot of the time there need to be
submissions made to the bank uh on
various aspects of of Regulation and uh
we put a lot of effort and are still
putting a lot of effort on into trying
to make that as uh as seem seamless and
streamlined as possible and that's part
of lots of ongoing work okay Travis on
your question I might need a explanation
on the penny scheme from off office
space from you this is not a serious
question um I will say office space is a
great film and I I enjoyed it I enjoyed
it
immensely I mean should we yeah so the
the premise for those that haven't seen
it is um it's a group of software
engineers and they they figure out a way
to on on top of every transaction of
which their Millions per day um take off
a fraction of a Penny or or something
like that and they become very rich on
the scheme and here in the US a lot of
us have to start paying back our student
loans this month so we're all looking
for our own Penny scheme so if there's a
way to use R to to help with that um
let's go I I will say something is I I
think I think for those who haven't
watched office space great great great
film um I think just the uh the the it's
it's amazing how the satirical element
of of of like what it is like to work in
an office hasn't really changed since
that film was made so it's it's it's
very good very good if somewhat
horrifying watching it is it is good
well thank you thank you for that
explanation there Travis um Marlene I
see you had a question in the chat too
you want to jump in oh sure um hello
everyone and Travis says in the side I
don't know why but my mind went to the
gag I can't even remember what movie or
phone it is but um the rotary phone
where they keep putting dimes in there
and then like you know so incrementally
somebody doesn't notice the weight and
all they take all the times out and he
just smacks himself with the phone
that's where my head went sorry welcome
to my brain um hi James thanks for
joining us um my question which is kind
of General but I I'm always fascinated
when I ask um f ask folks in the DAT
data science space this question what is
a challenge that maybe you faced and you
may still be encountering it may not
have overcome it but you didn't see it
coming um you know I think we all kind
of have these like okay we're ready to
kind of gird our loins for the
inevitable you know battles between
departments and governance issues um
sometimes it's political sometimes it's
just technical hurdles but what was
something maybe that kind of Blindsided
you um in the position that you're in
yeah yeah totally I think this is uh
this definitely got to me so I I spoke
before about uh like just how big the
bank is and how much data work goes on
and this had uh a an effect which I
wasn't quite prepared for but my
colleagues were very um uh good in
preparing me for uh it was uh because
part of this this data Consulting work
that that we do um we we have a kind of
a set of practices that we adopt um
which is that we try we have to like
upskill the business area to maintain
their own uh tooling so that if they
develop a process they have to be
responsible for maintaining it and I
came from a a different job where it was
like the data scientist would build and
maintain the tools and I'm a I'm a
maintainer at heart like I I maintain
like a bunch of our internal AR packages
um but my my boss had to to have a a
serious word with me as he does with
like everybody it says no no no we can't
maintain it and that's because if we
ever did uh we would so quickly become
overwhelmed with uh with with that
maintenance burden that that uh we
wouldn't be able to do anything else we
wouldn't be able to do anything new
um uh and that this was is is very
symptomatic of just the the having a
very big
organization and I was totally not
prepared for this um and so but but but
I but I wholeheartedly now am am am on
board with that and I think that just
speaks to you know you got to understand
your organization your organization's
needs and it might not be the same uh so
yeah it to to be perform you know to
perform well in different organizations
often mean some things even sometimes if
that means stepping back and saying you
know actually I need to coach somebody
through this I can't just do do it
myself um and so that that that was a a
big one for me yeah thank you so much
for that there's so much packed into
that by the by the way from a project
management perspective and scope creep
right because we I don't know about you
guys but I could tell you from the
handful of people I have interacted with
on this call you guys are a bunch of
fixers right so we don't like to leave
things um unhandled or kind of
straggling so we want to fix things and
I think maintenance is a huge part of
that and so kind of drawing clearcut
boundaries is something huge for a lot
of us so anyway thanks for sharing
appreciate your time my pleasure Tyler I
see you had a question in the chat um a
bit earlier do you want to jump in here
next yeah no um thank you James love the
insights really helpful especially from
the community here nice to meet you all
I think one of the things that struck me
most most with your thousand users I
wouldn't say I'm jealous um but we're
you know as we've we've rolled out posit
and some of the platforms we're ever in
this like struggle to get new users to
adopt successfully and happily to a new
platform um you know we love the things
we love about posits a little bit more
language agnostic it's a little bit more
open in that sense and a little bit more
flexible to the communities that we're
trying to serve in analytics and data
science right um but I'm just curious
like how do you guys handle that
conversion do you mandate training do
you how do you support those new users
um you know we're forever trying to you
know make the emac people's happy like
uh you know how do we how do we really
in that space develop like the kind of
like onboarding that can lead to what
you have demonstrated as a very
successful kind of adoption um that's a
little less top down and like here's a
new platform everybody on we're just
taking all the old stuff away but more
where you can get people to come and
really Excel and um
grow yeah and the answer the answer is
that they're on no easy answers so a lot
of the things that you've touched on we
do have dedicated training and dedicated
trainers and we have a schedule and uh
we we have excellent people in charge of
training who who who forward that on to
us uh documentation also important uh
together with that you know the kind of
offline asynchronous uh um uh resource
that people can can can consult I will
also say uh about documentation in
general writing is a delicate art so I I
think one of the thing that like makes a
difference to me is actually being given
time to to to write something properly
and so to give the user like a beginning
to end experience that is like
reproducible for them uh that is
underrated in my experience so whenever
I I do sometimes read a documentation
sometimes even my own which is not well
written and it wasn't because you know
the person writing it is bad it's just
because uh writing is hard uh and and
writing in a way that is clear and
concise to to a broadest range of people
is an underrated skill that we uh
absolutely should dedicate um time to
the third pillar of that is just uh
solving common problems as much as
possible so you know the the Holy Grail
of um uh of package roll outs or you
know um roll outs as uh uh platform roll
out rather is just the one liner just
can I solve this in one line is this
like a oneline thing that I can put in
and I can get the the experience and we
know that I mean everybody in this call
will know that it's never as easy as
that um so if you read like some GitHub
readmes and you know the the readme is
you know two two pages long and you know
requires some some some Linux
dependencies and um you know the you
know happens to works on my machine
syndrome and as much as you can get away
from that uh is is is best we do that I
do that how I try to do that by just uh
my my particular solution where I'm
where I'm good at is just to to build
our packages around it so we have a
range of our packages at the bank which
are specifically for data access so we
have you know X system and this system
has a way of interacting with that
particular data if it's a database or an
API or um or something more bespoke you
know just try and get it one line I just
want I just want one command that I can
that I can that can run and and it gets
the user from from zero to to Connected
um and as much of of that as you can as
you can you can give to users uh the
better um yeah never never never the
easiest thing but um as much as you can
do um you'll reap the
benefits thank you I see a big
discussion happening in the chat under
one of Mike's questions so I'm going to
come back to that but um there was a
slid question that someone asked
anonymously and it was how does the bank
manage
reproducibility of analysis I guess is
kind of touches on what you were just
talking about but especially with the
Thousand users with varying levels of
proficiency uh yeah totally so I I I
think it's it's again some training goes
into this I really think that posits um
uh posits tool set actually do this
incredibly well so the the reason that
you know our mark doesn't really have
like you can't just like embed uh you
can't just like reproduce tiny bits of
of our markdown it's really meant to be
like start to finish which basically
means uh this is something I didn't
realize till till after many years of
using it it's it's kind of like
reproducible by default and you actually
have to opt into the nonreproducible
bits and the same thing with you posit
connect and and and some others you know
there's um that that element is uh uh is
is really good um but otherwise it's
yeah just uh the the usual sorts of
things that people on this call will
will know about which is you know try
and make examples reproducible for
example in the the rep PR package uh a
lot about culture and just um you know
running things but also works in
combination with what I just said which
is it's easier if they have easy data
connections right so uh if you're able
to give some people a data connection
package then they can do it start to
finish and I think a lot of users are
actually quite good at they could they a
lot of users in in my experience are
quite good at spotting oh now I can run
this mm um because I've got this this
data connection I'm not working with
extracts um and I I I think that yeah
tooling is is a is a big part of that
thank you um Mike for the question and
discussion that's happening in the chat
do you mind jumping into kind of
summarize the the point for me I was
trying to multitask and figure out it
was and it was too hard yeah that's kind
of exploded sorry about that so um this
is coming back to James's point that um
when you develop stuff you definitely
don't want to own that solution forever
um or or you know maintain it because
then that it's like if you develop an
art package and you put it on to cran
you are forever the person who's GNA
have to make you know live live with
updating that forever um similarly with
in the business I'm in um we have a a
kind of policy that I think is similar
to what James was saying where if we're
developing something it's worth the time
to take to develop it in a way that the
people we hand it off to can can
maintain it
themselves you know maybe not
necessarily expand on it greatly but if
if there are bits they they tweak they
know where to tweak and they can get in
there and you know add a new variable or
you know change something from A to B
quite readily um I'm trying to get away
from sometimes what I see which is if
you if someone comes to you with a
problem you solve that problem and you
get it out the door as fast as possible
and you know it is what it is you just
deliver it and say well I'm done here
typically if you rush at it then it's
harder to for you and for anyone else to
maintain in the long term so it's a kind
of if you take a little bit longer and
get them the right Solution that's easy
for everyone to maintain going forward
it's it relieves the burden on everyone
I think that's what see I can't I can't
help but 100% endorse all of that um I I
only have like an example to add which
is like I think these these are just
these can be straightforward things like
function names so just like take time to
name your functions it's just uh it's
it's weird because it feels like like
make work but it's not actually actually
it's um uh just you know naming uh
naming functions and and naming
variables and stuff is just a a really
important part of someone else
understanding it in the future and then
being able to like audit it or um or or
debug it in the future um but yeah 100%
endorse and sorry to to kind of expand
on that another example is in um like
markdown documents or reports that you
construct for someone if you make them
parameterized and what you do is that
you feed in if if you ingest like a yaml
file or something that drives that
parameterization then they can always
expand it and add future parameters and
do all kinds of clever things with it um
but it then means that you're not kind
of locked into a given structure yeah
100% I think we stay here for a few more
minutes on this topic given all the the
comments there but uh Donald I see you
kind of asked a question in that for
like I guess help in convincing others
do you want to jump in here well I can
read it too and feel free to jump in
after but Donald had said in that thread
one of the biggest barriers I face in
building dashboards or packages is
convincing people that the work is worth
the maintenance cost from either my team
or theirs and would love additional
discussions around this or any thoughts
you
have yeah so um I I everything that I've
I've kind of said also applies to
dashboards so dashboard design is just
also a hugely underrated skill and uh
takes takes takes time and experience to
appreciate like what a when a good when
a good dashboard is made well um I uh uh
yeah I have the same quandry which is I
I try and say to to to managers or or
whomever I'm trying to convince is it's
it's much more uh it's it's much more
preferable to have a smaller number of
insights conveyed well and continuously
than to have a great wge of of insights
to you know com you know sort of
haphazardly um banded together um that
that the reason that's not always easy
is there's always somebody who wants
their favorite chart um and that's
that's where you kind of get this
dashboard fatigue phenomenon where you
know everybody wants to put their own
like bit on the Christmas tree and
eventually that the Christmas tree look
doesn't doesn't look good or Falls over
um and that's that that's a hard thing I
think just yeah manager gumption to say
that uh actually we we don't do this we
aren't going to support like every chart
uh we we're not going to support like
the the broadest um range of of of
possible visualizations for this thing
we want to focus on on on on core
insights um and things that the the
average person is trying to learn uh or
the the average person is going to want
to know out of your um your um your
output whether it's a dashboard or
whether that's something else thank
you um a question I had for you is
thinking about all the different teams
that I've spoken with probably thousands
of teams across six years um how like
what is your infrastructure look like in
terms of like testing and rolling out
new product I know like some teams might
have one server some have 10 servers and
they have their own production and
staging environment I was just curious
with supporting so many users what that
looks like for you yeah so this was a a
bit of a journey that the bank has been
on so as we've sort of like grown in in
a in a user base we we started to see
this a lot more that you know when we do
roll out a new version of R I'm kind of
now the person responsible for for
testing it but I can't test the code of
a thousand users uh for a stter like not
everybody is is is using Version Control
uh but you know we we are we are getting
there but yeah even if they were all
using Version Control uh we we don't
always have a good catalog of that and
that's part of what I've tried to do is
to try and get like a test bank so do
these are things which absolutely should
work uh so these are you know unit tests
and um and and regression test and
integration
tests um and our yeah philosophy is it's
a good idea um uh we try to get business
other areas of the of the bank to
contribute their code that's not always
easy because they're they're busy as
well um and uh it's um there there's a
couple blockers to be able to do that
but I will also say that it's uh again
something which just takes time and
energy so you know I I invest quite a
lot of time in putting together our our
our test Suites now and uh it's it's
hard in the short term but but pays a
lot of dividends in in the long term the
other thing which is a bit useful for
that is um so I my area of focus is kind
of on our data warehouse so not
everything in the bank is based around
its data warehouse there um there are
parts that are outside that but the data
warehouse is a good I want to say forum
for uh that kind of testing because it
is you know where a lot of things can
end up or should end up and so uh my
sort of like I I'm also party
responsible for the the tooling on the
data warehouse so that's my way of
bringing it together um it might be
similar for for those on this on this
call um but yeah just as much as
possible try and get people on board to
test it themselves or ask them to
contribute it or you know reach out and
and and ask their permission to grab it
uh
yourself um yeah certainly worthwhile
doing thank
you um um yeah I guess I just think a
lot about the teams who Maybe started
out with just a few users and are
starting to grow and need to expand that
infrastructure and how to like
know what to do there what the next
steps
are um I see like lots of conversation
here happening in the chat here I'm
trying to pull out the questions so feel
free to just raise your hand here if you
have something that wasn't really
answered yet um
but there's a lot of discussion
happening around like dashboard design I
think once we me mentioned like
dashboard
fatigue um and Eric I see you had a a
shout out to one of the conference
workshops if you want to jump in
here yeah that was um I was privileged
to be a TA at David Gren and Maya gan's
Workshop about effective design
principles for shiny dashboards at pacov
and I highly recommend checking that out
as well as David's book on outstanding
shiny user interfaces and with the toing
that now is in shiny itself in
particular with BS lib it's becoming a
lot easier to incorporate some of these
best practices of design without you
know being an official you know ux
designer with you know years of training
it's it's something that I think a lot
of people are be able to pick up on and
hopefully avoid some of the dashbo
fatigue that can occur yeah I'll say
something a bit about this I am
constantly struck
by just how similar well I mean the name
does it does it justice right this is
design and design is hard right so
design is you know takes place in all
all facets of Life often
underappreciated uh easy to ignore even
when it's done right just like all
designers um but I I kind of feel of the
same way about dashboards I do about
good writing so you know good writing
starts well right you know the first
sentence should like Engage The Reader
in the same way that like the first
thing that the the dashboard shows you
should be um the the the most important
thing or something not necessarily
gripping but you know something which
you you you would hope would would
introduce the the the rest of the the
the concepts which are to to follow
again structure is important I mean
we're very good as humans I well I guess
because our our education has focused us
on how to structure text very well
because you know we we get uh lots of
lots of training
on this uh in so far as we have um you
know you know structure headings um
citations and things like that um and we
don't really get it for dashboards but a
lot of the uh the same uh the same
things apply notably some some
exceptions too but um but but I see them
as as very similar uh especially asking
yourself the question or sorry answering
the question on behalf of the user you
know what what are you trying to
communicate to them what question do
they have that you're trying to answer
and what goes along with that is you
don't want to answer trivial questions
you don't but you also don't want to you
know answer uh you don't want to lead
with a question which is impossibly
difficult to understand and all of that
is design and um and yeah we should have
design focused um teaching which I'm I'm
sure that that Workshop that you
mentioned Eric was was primed to do
absolutely and uh Ted I feel like there
needs to be a shout out to your comment
here in the
the chat here as well um where Ted said
a good dashboard is often the product of
subtraction not addition too and I see a
lot of other thoughts here shared on
design does anybody else want to jump in
yeah I mostly use subtraction because I
knew Libby was going to take the bait so
but I think there is something to be
said about you know pairing things down
and
editing and people don't really think
about
that okay people a few more seconds if
anybody has anything else they want to
add on the design topic but um James I I
think it would also be interesting to
hear a little bit more
about the like the organization and how
you have like yourself as the r business
owner for the business represent
representative and then you have this
Tech representative and it just feels
like that would be a
helpful I don't know team to have in
many different companies so I was
wondering like how long has it been that
way or did your team like kind of start
that or did you have to advocate for
that no so this this definitely predates
me at the bank so yes more than a few
years now um and I think we're uh yeah
just sort of grown out of the of an
extending user base it's maybe worth
mentioning that you know we have this
for a couple of our tools now and some
of the tools we group together um but
python certainly has a its own business
owner and Technology owner um and we we
have some other internal tools which do
that as well and and arguably we will
have some more um when the the the
community inside the bank grows to to a
large enough size uh yeah I I mean I I
find it uh you know a very healthy
construct to to to have uh with with so
many users and again you know I think if
you took if you took any of those roles
away you would detract from the quality
of service that that the users are able
to uh to to enjoy uh but I didn't have
it at the the previous place I worked
and um but um yeah if people I'm sure
they have been shouting out in the chat
if if not they um uh uh then uh but uh
if if not then yeah they can shout out
now that uh yeah maybe other
organizations have it if maybe not under
the same names I see there's a question
in the chat about adopting new tools I
don't know if somebody wants to shout
that out um yeah I think it was Marlene
yeah it's me again I'm just curious so
like how how amendable or agile is your
team specifically about adopting
languages Tech
Etc yeah so I would say that there's a
balance and with uh with with important
work we we will off we will facilitate
um there so what the one thing to bear
in mind is the bank is quite sensitive
about security so we we have a you know
policies on on what can be installed um
which I think is fairly common at many
organizations and so yeah we we try and
and and balance the concerns of wanting
to adopt new technologies and uh and
wanting to to to be secure but also not
to um uh to uh adopt something too
quickly and the part of the reason is
that sometimes uh you know you can get
bitten on this so somebody develops a
business critical process uh in in a
language that's not supported and you
know people will will move on to other
roles um and and and perhaps leave a
bank and you know there's a there's a
maintenance burden which which goes
along with that which we have to be
mindful of and yeah those are the the
competing concerns and so I I think we
uh I'm on board with the idea that we
have to
um uh we have to to balance things so
there there are some there is a bit of
work happening with Julia right now um
uh but uh yeah we we haven't sort of uh
promoted it to to fully fledged support
yet and then we might not you um Libby I
think you have asked a question that was
kind of in line with what I was trying
to ask earlier and didn't I didn't ask
it as great as you did so love to have
you jump in here with your question
around um the our Excellence Hub yeah so
um and I did get an answer which was
great um I've only ever lived the
experience of you can't use these
packages you can use these packages and
the packages I want to use never being
on the list of packages that I can't use
right so I was always sitting around
wondering is there a land out there
where there's like a Dev environment
where I can just use whatever package I
want and create a case for hey I think
we should use this package hey I think
we should put this through some testing
to make sure that it's safe and then you
know put it on the list um and it looks
like I had one answer saying yes I'm
curious if anybody else has and and
James if you have any feedback or
experience with
it yeah simply what I've what I've what
I've said before we we try and you know
balance these concerns as much as we
can it's such a selfish question as as a
data end user I see lots of people like
nodding but I also know that on the
regulatory end of it it's important to
not just let people use any package they
want and any version they want and it's
yeah Mike's like
no so I get it um but that's a tough
question right how to balance
that I see um May you had shared some
thoughts there do you wanna do you want
to jump
in thank you and thank you for the great
engines so uh we kind of had multiple
production servers based on geographies
so we used to work on re Insurance
organization and due to data privacy
issues know each geography in Europe or
Asia so there would be eight or nine
different production servers but there
would be only one Dev environment and
nobody would you know really look at Dev
environment there would be often times
like a data scientist like or myself
would want to know use something out of
the let's say shiny live or that's so
they we would ask them to go to De play
as much as they would want to and then
once you know we'll get the sign up
we'll Implement those in also whenever
posit would come up with new updates to
know their products in terms of the
first install on Des we would have a
series of script to do the testing if
you know code based deployments are
working or am I able to use G plot and
you know basic stuff once we get a
report out of that you know we will then
move everything to Pro all the updates
and we will do the same regression
testing again on that so that we are
kind of shielded from immediate updates
and as an organization we are able to
give users the latest and the best so
that's how we use D BR service yeah I
love that thank you so much for sharing
um before jumping to another question
James just want to make sure did you
have anything else you wanted to add
there uh no
no um as we get to the close to the top
of the hour
just a reminder missed anything in the
chat I'm so sorry feel free to just
raise your hand as to ask a question
here too or just copy it over and and
ask it again if that's okay um let me go
double check over to slido as
well um but one of the like people
oriented questions I love to ask James
is about career advice that you've
either been given or have given and so
like thinking back is there a piece of
career advice that really like stands
out to you so I would love to to hear it
oh that's a good question
um I think the thing that
I uh it's it's G to sound very obvious
but it's just to to to really get
enjoyment out of what you do just to I
think that that probably speaks to to a
lot of people on the call all given uh
you know your attendance here today but
just being interested in in in subject
matter that that your work is involved
in is uh just huge for your for your
motivation and your your ability to
continue with it um uh so so that's
that's that's really excellent uh but I
think it's not good career advice
perhaps but uh it's always just to to
keep perspective about what your career
is and what your job is and that you
know you should you should never be um
sort of um hamstrung or um or bound to
to to a particular career or company or
or anything like that uh it's just to to
to to assess as rationally as you can
the the situation you're in and where
you want to be um and uh to to to cash
out to to to you know to to take time
for yourself and to to make sure you um
you have that that that balance of the
considerations that you care about um
which is not not very exciting uh not
not very novel advice um but um I think
again it's going to be super obvious to
the people on this call but um if you if
you do get a chance I do think
programming is transformative so I mean
we are on this call are probably long
past the stage where you know we uh have
we are surprised at the power of
programming but if you think back to
your past selves uh certainly back to my
past self which is just the the ability
to to use code to to to interact with
the various parts of of your life or
your work um uh was definitely a a a
changing point for me and so I I don't
mind advising people to to take up code
because I know what what code and
software um has done for me and it
happens to be you know re a reasonably
good career Prospect at the same time
and so what a fantastic thing for us to
be able to to engage in something which
is which is both hugely interesting
hugely rewarding and and and has good
career prospects along along the way so
not not advice to to anybody watching
this maybe even to to people watching
the stream but um you know if uh if you
are asked to about advice I I I think
you know just learning to code is is is
such a pH phal um lifechanging
experience that um that it's worth
emphasizing thank you for
that is there a specific story that
you'll share with people who you're
talking to who are interested in
learning like to show them that impact
yeah for sure well I I'll tell you a bit
about my experience of learning um so I
learned I one of the so I grew up in
South Africa um and one of the things
that happened happens in South Africa
it's changed a lot now but South South
Afric internet us of South African is is
far removed from from what you might
encounter in the west so uh especially
with the availability of of internet
data and so what you'll get is it's
changed quite a lot now but sou Africans
used to like turn off the data on their
phone because they were afraid of being
charged on their on their mobile plan
because they you know internet was was
was very expensive and so um uh or it
used to be very expensive and so what I
would do is I would go to the the
University library and I would find a
way to download YouTube videos so I
would um I listen to to some talks on on
Python and and and all this was
important for my studying but I I
downloaded them because I knew it' be
too expensive to to watch them all um in
my um uh in in my flat at home uh even
though I'm you know by by South African
standards very very well off um but you
know just it wasn't worth it from from
that perspective um and so you know
these these demonstrations which were
were video recorded were just like gold
dust to me they were like you know
something which I as somebody who lived
many many thousands of well you know
thousands of kilometers away uh could
could experience this this world and I
got insight into this world and and live
demonstrations and I'm very very
grateful for that um changed my life and
um uh yeah just uh you know that that's
a story that I'll I'll tell you know
having to to download those those
YouTube videos and I of course you watch
them on repeat because you could never
download enough so ended up watching
them uh quite a lot um now of course I
have a much better experience of of
watching of watching YouTube but um I
would also say that that kind of
reinforces the notion of uh of of video
so I know that you know some conferences
and and some speakers understandbly
don't don't want to be video but it is
it is so so appreciated by people who
who cannot be in the room with you um
and there are there are kids in in other
parts of the world who will watch that
who will go out of their way to watch
that and um and you're always uh
speaking to them absolutely I love that
thank thank you so much for sharing that
James my pleasure thank you for having I
know we have uh two minutes left here
and I realized Eric I had missed one of
your questions from earlier if you want
to jump in here with one of the the last
questions yeah I mean certainly James
you don't have to answer all this fully
in the time we have but just curious
from your standpoint of all the data you
mentioned that you're dealing with at
the bank are there uses of r with other
novel technologies that are enabling a
lot more you know speed or performance
for your your data science teams as
you're crunching through this vast
amount of
data so yeah in the in the middle
section there's definitely data table so
data table is great uh data table
you know slightly uh yeah underrated R
technology but when you have something
which uh a lot of people try to take out
of the database uh and and want to work
on on on really big data but they need
the performance also a lots of people
like data table for for its syntax so um
so that's uh that's great um a lot of
the things so I guess we are now um just
starting on this journey like anybody of
llms and so we have a hackathon quite
soon just to see the we're not using it
in in in Earnest yet there's just a
couple of um things that are that are
being planned and we we'll see what
comes out of that of course we do do
text mining so text mining uh the bank
has a a network of Agents across the
country and those agents report to us on
they they do interviews and they report
to us on the state of of different um uh
Industries and and businesses and so Tex
mining is very very fruitful for for be
able to to extract insights from that um
so uh yeah like I said before it's it's
hugely varied um uh so the bank is very
data set hungry and um those are just
some of the some of the ways that we
that we utilize R in particular awesome
thank you thank you so much James for
for joining us today and and sharing
your perspective I is a to me too to
also say thank you to everybody who ends
up watching these Hangouts on YouTube in
the future as well I just want to say
like you all are part of this community
as well even if you're not here with us
in the room maybe you're watching on
YouTube and commenting and sharing with
others as well um but a special thank
you as well to everybody here for all
the great questions today I um I had so
much fun getting to meet so many of you
at the conference and also just wanted
to say like amazing job on all of the
conference talks it was so fun just like
running around to try and like catch as
many of the data science hangout folks
talks um or whether you were watching
those virtually or there in person in
Chicago so thanks everybody for making
this community what it is and hope you
all have a great rest of the day thank
you bye everybody
goodby